[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es wieder
was herzhaftes wir machen kapser das ist
ein extrem leckeres reisgericht sehr
sehr orientalisch gewürzt und obendrauf
geben wir sehr witzige hähnchenschenkel
also für mich auch so ein bisschen
festessen charakter also immer wenn wir
zb dieses familie sind und dort ganz
viele personen von essen dann macht
meine schwiegermama einen ganz großen
teller also ungefähr die dreifache menge
die ich jetzt heute mache und dann essen
einfach alle aus diesem großen teller
sie das schiff sich da so ein bisschen
was ab und ich freue mich immer wenn es
das gibt sondern zeige ich euch wie das
funktioniert wir starten jetzt hier in
der pfanne da gebe ich jetzt butter rein
ihr wisst ja mutter darf man nicht so
hoch erhitzen deswegen macht gern er
nimmt gern die mittlere stufe da gebe
ich auch noch ein bisschen butter jeder
zu einfach weil ich den geschmack mag
die ich jetzt auch mit rein dass ich das
schmelzen und dann geben wir zimtstangen
und 5km um kapseln mit dazu
[Musik]
so nach etwa einer minute gibt ihr dann
immer dazu den habe ich schön fein
gehackt und knoblauch einfach rein
pressen und das dann auch eine minute
lang andünsten wichtig ist also wirklich
die mittlere stufe weil es ist ja kein
hoch erhitzt bares öl sondern butter und
da gebe ich jetzt zwiebeln mit dazu die
habe ich auch grob gehackt einfach mit
andünsten so ungefähr zwei minuten und
dann kommen weitere gewürze mit dazu
überhaupt generell sehr viele gewürze
hier einige davon gibt es auch in meinem
shop
ich habe aber auch eine gewürzmischung
muss ich ehrlich sagen extra eine
gewürzmischung für kapser aber ich habe
gleichzeitig den originalen weg so und
jetzt kommen die gewürze dazu die das
ganze schön köstlich machen kreuz kümmel
nelken koriander der hamas alle etwas
chili salz und pfeffer und jetzt gebe
ich tomaten dazu lösche das ganze so ein
bisschen ab davids tomaten aus der dose
die werden der erntefrisch konserviert
ihr könnt aber auch frische tomaten
nehmen und einfach treiben die hier sind
ohne haut also achtet darauf dass wir
wenn ihr frische tomaten nimmt auch die
haut einfach weglassen so einfach mit
dazu geben und dann so ungefähr fünf
minuten lang köcheln lassen
[Musik]
so und jetzt geben wir hähnchenschenkel
dazu könnte zum beispiel auch
hähnchenkeule nehmen und braten das von
beiden seiten circa drei bis fünf
minuten an so und im anschluss geben wir
wasser dazu weil jetzt muss das fleisch
im wasser garen also wasser so viel dazu
geben das ist gerade so das fleisch
bedeckt dann einmal aufkochen lassen und
damit geschlossenem deckel ca steht etwa
25 minuten köcheln lassen das kommt
natürlich immer darauf an wie viel
fleisch gehabt ob stick ist oder
zigaretten kurzen aussetzer ob es
relativ dick ist oder ein bisschen
flacher und dann müssen einfach schauen
dass es gerade so durch ist
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich einmal das hähnchen raus
und gibt das gleich auch noch mal in den
backofen damit von oben und unten
richtig schön kross gewählt werden kann
so und da in dem grenzort wird gleich
reis gekocht habe ich auch schon
abgewaschen ihr wisst ihr eis enthält
viel stärke daher immer abwaschen damit
er eben nicht klebt dann zeige ich euch
gleich nochmal eine sehr interessante
zutat
[Musik]
und jetzt sollte der reis komplett
bedeckt sein könnte noch ein bisschen
wasser nachgießen ihr könnt aber auch im
nachhinein erst machen wenn ihr merkt
dass er nicht ganz klar ist bei mir hat
jetzt genau perfekte reicht das wegen
des klaren und dann geht er richtig
schön fein und jetzt kommt die
interessante zutat und zwar habe ich
hier getrocknete limetten es gibt auch
getrocknete zitronen die sind dann
komplett schwarz und die schmecken auch
sauer und die gibt man einfach so rein
weil ich weiß dass ihr die schwer
bekommt lasse ich jetzt und zeige euch
die alternative das wird aber in der
arabischen küche total gerne verwendet
sind die alternative ja diesen mega
hardy sind getrocknet also ich fand
interessant und ich habe jetzt hier
alternativ einfach zitronenscheiben die
müsste jetzt für den typischen geschmack
jetzt einfach noch mit dazu gebe ich
hatte das gerade einmal kurz aufkochen
lassen was auch noch mit dazu kommt ganz
typisch sind möhren die müsst ihr ganz
einfach fein raspeln gebe ich jetzt auch
noch mit dazu und dann las ich das auf
niedriger stufe also ich nämlich stufe 2
von 980 das garen mit geschlossenem
deckel denke mal das braucht so ungefähr
25 minuten und die ganz genauen
mengenangaben die schreibe ich euch wie
immer unten in der video beschreibung
auf
[Musik]
die letzten schritte vor dem servieren
sind folgende das fleisch einmal bei 190
grad ober und unterhitze 15 bis 20
minuten nochmal den ofen geben es kommt
wie gesagt auf die dicke des fleisches
an
wir wollen dass die haut noch mal schön
kross wird und dann werde ich nur noch
cashewkerne anbraten in butter ihr könnt
doch mandl nehmen oder pinienkerne auch
sehr lecker aber müsse in kombination
mit reis so lecker und was auch noch
typisch ist sind rosinen auch einfach in
butter anbraten
denkt dran mittlere stufe butter darf
nicht so sehr erhitzt werden und dann
servieren wir alles gemeinsam mit einer
großen schüssel und dann kann jeder
davon essen mega mega lecker und sehr
toll gewürz probiert es unbedingt aus
und schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare
ob ihr das gericht schon kannte oder ob
es neu für euch ist ich hoffe dass wir
fasten ja gerade und nach dem
fastenbrechen wird haben sie ja
probieren und ich hoffe haben sah dass
ich es wieder nicht geschafft habe sagte
die ich da sind hohe ansprüche weil sie
macht es einfach perfekt aber ich hoffe
dass ich den ansprüchen ein bisschen
gerecht werde
wir schauen mal ich denke mal da folgt
wieder mal eine instagram story zu
machen was also euch einen wunderschönen
tag hinterlässt gerne ein abo wenn ihr
es nicht schon längst getan habt und
dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten
leckeren rezepten
[Musik]